in today's world of like multimedia
where everyone even a-list stars have
like 11
you know projects going it's really
strange how let's say you have a big
deal with netflix
i i don't know this for a fact but let's
use him as an example let's say bill
burr right
they're paying him a lot of money to do
a tv show at netflix it's weird how a
lot of their
um code of conduct can bleed into his
other
work yes where they're like you can't go
making i'm not saying this happens with
bill burr but
he's an example um you can't say so and
so in your comedy stand-up or you can't
go do
a podcast where you talk about this
issue because we're giving you
seven million dollars so and it's like
really what
i don't work for you over here you know
that that's that's a little that's a
really weird thing the good news is that
for the most part you can say whatever
the [ __ ] you want you can't though
i mean really you're gonna depending if
you're if you're a comic you sure as
[ __ ] can't yeah no you can't yeah you
can't no way if you work for a
corporation
no way if you work for if you work for
netflix if you have a big podcast that's
what i'm saying
you're just collecting your checks going
around the country going to comic con if
you're
so you guys you can do whatever you want
you guys are the last
last hope for like the idea of the
american idea of like you know of like
mark twain or or or great thinkers
because it depends what truly depends
what you want if you're a bill burr if
you're
especially the best examples or a good
friend joe rogan rogan can
do whatever the [ __ ] he wants to do he
has [ __ ] you money
outside that there's not you know here
you gotta remember i work for showtime i
work for a complex i
you know i i still have to i don't have
[ __ ] you might as well go watch my
piecing
but i would say this i would say this um
i'm not allowed to say things i wouldn't
say anyway
a lot of times right so so what i mean
by this is this
i don't say things that are like anti
i don't say racist things never thought
they were funny i don't make jokes like
that
i never liked doing no they're not funny
but what i'm saying is that we don't do
that anyway you wouldn't be you
i wouldn't right i'm not your boss you
know what i'm saying but do you know
what i mean
i mean i'm kind of running hey wait a
minute i'm sorry but you know what i'm
saying we don't really
it's just stuff anyway but you want to
be i i wouldn't put up with it
like if you're saying wait wait wait
wait wait what if there there's there's
racist comedy it's [ __ ] straight
funny and can be useful well dude if
it's like dave chappelle
joke about about yeah i'm a little
racist like if i walk into a pizza joint
and it's a bunch of black women making
my pizza
i'll be like all right well maybe this
is the best you keep walking and just
see if there's another pizza
that's [ __ ] genius but that that's
all funny but but
at the end of the day i i think the
things that you're not allowed to say
when i see like this nick cannon stuff i
don't say that [ __ ] anyway
mainly because i don't want to hurt
anybody it's not who you are i just
don't want her
but i think there's a freedom with a guy
like rogan or you know i think
chappelle's the best comic to ever do it
there's a freedom with chappelle
where you're not going to cancel them so
like when you watch a special you might
like oh he's going to get some hot water
for that
he doesn't give a [ __ ] what are you
going to do yeah
corolla's a good example dude corolla's
a great example you if you listen to
what corolla says
carol if you're if you're if you're not
a cro if you're anti-corona bro so those
people who think corona is the end of
the world and the economy should be shut
down for the next five years and
we should all lock down our house it's
only get worse if you're that dude
you don't listen to corolla don't listen
to uh clay travis because those guys
don't answer to a boss
and they give you facts and just shoot
from the [ __ ] hip like when corolla
starts sticking up for jimmy kimmel
there's nothing better man cause you
tell their best friends it'd be like if
you were going through the same [ __ ]
corolla just [ __ ] sticks it to him
yeah she's great intent matters too
though i also go for kimmel
me too intent matters a big deal like
if someone puts on blackface for the
sake of putting on blackface to harm
someone to hurt their
that's that's honestly the most
repugnant that's one of the more
republicans
i just wouldn't want to hurt somebody's
feelings right i mean you understand
you're saying
i'm going to put on a costume that
brings terror to people that reminds
people
of years and years of of oppression now
if you're
painting your skin black so that you can
better resemble carl malone yeah that's
a big [ __ ] difference
but that's what that's exactly that goes
back to my point mike it's like
let's look at the body of work of jimmy
kimmel for the past
20 years man has he ever say anything
racist has he done any of that rates his
[ __ ] no
no and then you point towards this one
car malone skit that he did
which was funny yeah but you know i i
guarantee if you ask him to do it now
he'd never do it or how about fallon
dude he did blackface making fun of his
friend chris rock chris
next to him well again look at the body
of words the most most of the people
that i know that i'm friends with
wouldn't um they're not they're not
racist
like uh when nobody's looking and they
don't do it like
like think about it for a second like to
be mean
and to be that ignorant i don't really
want you around you're you know that
this is
most of us right i mean here's the thing
absolutely
i remember said to rogan i said one time
when he was like 28 and he was a [ __ ]
boston kid
you know like like when nanette that
that that hannah gatsby came out and
said
straight white men better pull their
socks up because i got the [ __ ] beat out
of me because i was gay
i don't know a [ __ ] straight dude i
i'm serious
i don't know a [ __ ] straight dude
that i would hang out with who was a
friend of mine
that wouldn't have come to her defense
if if any of my friends
saw hannah gatsby getting the [ __ ]
kicked at her by some [ __ ]
dude i would [ __ ] that dude i don't beat
him i gotta be honest
the [ __ ] out because we'd be like you're
beating up this woman who's gay any
woman she's gay i'd
[ __ ] stomp you i didn't i wouldn't
realize that she was gay
i would be stomping on your [ __ ] hand
but most of my friends
stupid face
just really quickly he's 28 and he goes
i thought he was a bro from boston i
said you know
i've never heard you say a prejudice
thing and you're a boston
jersey guy you know and he just goes
it's so funny he goes because i'm not a
[ __ ] idiot
like what do you mean he goes i go hey i
grew up i lived in boston new jersey
you want to see really dumb white people
i'll take you to see really dumb white
people too because well dude
never mind bill burr's life is black the
kid is half black
right but you know kimmel's going to
lose his job
you think yes okay he's going to lose
his job over that mm-hmm
he's on he's on break right now do you
know that cancer culture is ready
castle culture is real they're letting
them bow out with grace
ah you want a bet he hm okay he'll find
another i don't know i don't know
if he'll find another job i mean oh yeah
on what network
i mean he would maybe do the match with
corolla he can go on a podcast and make
millions of dollars
abc nbc cbs ain't gonna hire him
okay wait wait but here's the thing
that's what that will this one
he's bound out with they're going you
know we gotta get rid of you guys i do
i'm about with grace do you think though
maybe let's say you'd say you're right
and he he he is released from his job as
host of jimmy kimmel
don't you think that there would be
such a huge groundswell of support for
him in his next job
because the the the really the
population
of people that get crazy over really
unreasonable stuff
like this small it's very small and i
think they're the loudest
instagram and i think people on twitter
if kimmel then went to uh
a podcast or or a netflix show that
people would be like oh he's that guy
who didn't apologize and said hey i
wasn't
being raped i was i know i know i'll
fall in love and i just think that maybe
there would be
especially nowadays where everyone feels
so persecuted by everything who doesn't
like
who does i think he's the best host
there is super nice who wouldn't follow
him he's always been
get him on the podcast i would follow
him but i don't think he's doing a lot
of podcasts
having some issues um why not right now
yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected